do you think it's true that women will  make rules for the wrong guy but break  rules for the right guy I do I do  believe that  I think so too well I mean sometimes you  like the bad boys so we tend to break  the rules for them do you think that  women tend to lust after bad boys but  want to settle down with nice guys oh we  sure do I love a bad boy what's  attractive about a bad boy they just  have that quality that just is so  attractive how do bad boys treat women  horrible so then what why would you want  to be with a bad boy when they treat you  badly because they do other things that  the good ones don't like what I don't  want to go there  we know we know